this is probably how ariana grande cooks
and I curse a lot to curse yeah I don't
want to this is Brian and today I'm with
tasty to cook my favorite type of eggs
and it will be called the omelet
I have an Chetta which is like fancy
bacon cheese that was like problem I
think pink Himalayan salt some butter
some chives some shape truffles which
I'm not sure if I'm gonna use I just
asked them for because I wanted to eat
it to be honest with you and eggs let's
get started
I am just whisking the eggs I really
wish I could crack eggs with one hand a
lot of people do that and I can't let me
try oh my god I I mean I kind of did it
I'm gonna do three eggs today I haven't
had a proper breakfast and I kind of I
get to eat this right do I see it it
okay cool whisking the eggs I'm gonna
put a little bit of salt and pepper in
it I don't want to like put a crazy
amount just cuz I feel like the pancetta
is gonna be pretty salty pink Himalayan
salt is better for you somebody told me
that and I think that's what I choose to
believe I don't want to like look into
it more placebo is a real thing and like
you know if I truly believe that it's
good for me then it will be good for me
that's all that matters turn on the
stove I'll do like a nice medium high
what I'm gonna do is put a little bit of
butter in it I'm gonna try to cut this
up a little bit make little pancetta
dice then I will put it in the pan and
turn this down some more cooking is like
my favorite thing to do to relax I love
when I just have a bunch of ingredients
and I don't know what to do with it I
just kind of lay try to come up with a
dish on the spot it's nice because you
kind of impress yourself a little bit I
love just like asking my parents for
recipes you know like dishes that I
would eat when I was growing up and then
I'm like I missed this so I can't find
it anywhere and I like I make them it's
kind of its kind of spot on surprisingly
what I'm going to do right now is put
the pancetta in let it render a little
bit there's not that much hearing
I'm gonna put the stop alarm create a
confection heat so that he kind of goes
just like around and then it gets
trapped and then it's kind of like I'm
basically steaming my pancetta right now
I think that's time typically proven
yeah turn it down now and then put the
lid on the pancetta like I wanted to be
all small and cute there's multiple
kinds of cheese here I'm curious about
it so I'm gonna try it a little bit
I assume this is provolone because it's
circular not tasting lunch to be honest
with you it kind of seems like one of
those like like wonton skins but like a
little bit sour and this is kind of a it
could either be cheddar or American
cheese definitely a lot more flavor
Annette honestly I can't tell the
difference between cheddar in America
and this it looks like a piece of gum
like a cheese flavored gum hmm I like
that one the best
Wow now one kind of tastes like orange I
really like that the pancetta looks
pretty good to me right now I want to
pour that again and I'm gonna try my
best not to have too much coloration on
the eggs when I'm at home I just kind of
do whatever I want but I learned how to
make an omelet from a French chef and he
taught me to like do everything with low
heat I kind of forgot most of it to be
honest with you but I'm gonna like try
to just kind of do what I remember you
know what I'm gonna put it off the heat
because you can do that sometimes you
don't have to have it on the heat all
the time omelets are my favorite type of
eggs because you can put so many things
in it thing that we do in Indonesia I
put like sweet soy sauce in the omelet
mix and it has this kind of like sweet
kind of like caramelized flavor and then
you put like pieces of like chili and
them in the eggs and it's just as
beautiful what I'm doing right now is
I'm basically doing like a manually
shredded cheese
that's totally fine I forgot and I'm
gonna own up to my mistakes I'm gonna
put the cheese on like one side of it I
am going to kind of roll the egg a
little bit and kind of like flip it to
one side and I really hope I don't mess
up he did it kind of slowly so he did
this this style of cooking omelet once
that's that's where this is fun I was
gonna close it a little bit and let the
cheese melt
but you know what I might do that
actually this might take a while but at
the same time when we were cooking it
we were we were cooking it in very low
heat but we were using a different type
of cheese there's more like a cream
cheese kind of situation so I I'm I just
I minutes ago Rove I'm turning the heat
up all the way the plans have changed
I'm gonna make this my own type of
omelet I'm gonna put the cheese in the
middle now I'll put the lid on when it's
kind of like almost done I like to like
flip it so it's like it's like half way
and then I like to sear both sides until
it's nice and medium-rare the cheese is
starting to melt a little bit I can see
that through the glass oh this smells
beautiful
boom it has beautiful color coloration
here I'm gonna put the butter in there
I'm gonna try to get it under the egg
let me see what the other side looks
like okay there's there's a good amount
of color but it can have some more I'm
gonna open the truffles actually just
okay actually turn this off get the
garnishes ready cut the chives up it
adds a huge kind of like texture to em
--let it's like an extra star at the
restaurant so this is the omelet the
chives on top you see how that looks oh
that looks so cool it doesn't feel like
an amateur is making it it fills the
empty space and adds kind of like
texture and accents I went to full sales
so I know about graphic design I want to
know if this needs truffle so I'm gonna
try it by itself first
that's pretty mild I feel like I will
incorporate some truffle on it put it on
the omelet in a way that's like that's
pretty yeah well right when the stove
just turns off that's a sign that we
should stop so here you go this is the
omelet I'm really excited to try it but
before I try it
we're gonna bring Anka and make sure you
have some chives on that Cheers Wow
I like it since anything it is I think
the salt is just kind of dominating the
take the flavor of Nashua thank you I
appreciate it thank you I'm gonna eat
the rest of this now because I haven't
had breakfast so I really hope you know
we learn how to do this too at home
because it's pretty simple and if you do
make it make sure the time you own
histogram at Bryan Emanuel be sure to
check out my music I just put out an
album called the Sailor really proud of
the album I think you should listen to
it it's a great album this is Ben the
omelet and I'm rich Bryan and thank you
for watching
[Music]